we do have one vehicle that's on fire
fully involved another vehicle is
also involved in accidents not on fire
it was like we have two people sitting
on the sidewalk
thank you for joining us at 11 i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis less
than 24 hours after he was involved in a
deadly crash the las vegas raiders have
released henry ruggs from the football
team that crash happened in the
southwest valley early this morning
police say the woman that rugs hit was
killed and his girlfriend was in the car
with him and seriously hurt madison
kimbrell live from right where that
crash happened with our top story
tonight
this crash happened here on rainbow
boulevard you're taking a look at it
right now in between tropicana and
spring valley known for having cars
speed up and down at all hours of the
day and night neighbors say this is a
common but unfortunate situation
i'm sorry for the victims family i'll be
praying for everybody even the
football player sorry for both parties a
horrific scene tuesday morning as
22-year-old las vegas raiders wide
receiver henry ruggs iii was speeding
down rainbow in a chevrolet corvette
when he veered off and crashed into a
woman's rav4 from behind that woman just
23 years old died one neighbor recalls
seeing everything from his house i grab
my phone run outside in my undies look
over my wall
and i see a corvette smashed front end
sitting up against across the street
and i see
i guess it's a toyota sitting on miller
street with sparks coming from it rug's
girlfriend 22 year old kiara jenae kilgo
washington was in the passenger seat and
is said to be seriously injured and i
can hear him speeding just speeding down
rainbow
if you actually look where the corvette
was behind that light post
that wall has been rebuilt two or three
times
and it's
honestly it's sad ruggs is facing two
felony charges dui resulting in death
and reckless driving resulting in death
in the state of nevada this is a class b
felony and rugs could face anywhere from
two to 20 years in jail we're still
awaiting details from police on the
victim's identity along with rugg's
girlfriend and how her condition is
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now